on loan from NBC Sports Hall of Fame
coach joining us Continental Tire
Coaches Corner
let me start with the Eagles last night
tone what did you make of the Rams
losing at home well I tell you what I
just think that those Eagles have a lot
of confidence a lot of faith in Nick
Foles and I think they got back in
desperation mode that's how they
operated last year kind of as the
underdog and that suits them I thought
they'd play relaxed and I think there's
also a little something wrong with the
Rams offense I'm not sure what's missing
we're not saying that explosive plays we
saw earlier in the year if I'm a Rams
fan the biggest concern I have right now
the level of concern is what I wouldn't
be overly concerned but Jared Golf has
got to get back to playing the way he
can play I thought Shawn McVeigh did a
great job last night I thought he might
force the issue too much with golf but
he really did try to get Todd Gurley
going he dialed up some things that were
easy throws but golf golf missing throws
that he normally makes and I just would
be worried about his psyche at this
point best team in the NFC right now
with two weeks to go is who I think the
Saints are going to be very very tough
to beat at home we were there on
Thanksgiving night and they just when
they get in that building they play fast
they play with a lot of energy they've
got defenders who can pressure the
pastor and Drew Brees you know he's very
very confident right now and all of his
weapons so I think there's a beat in the
NFC how do you explain the Colts over
the Cowboys oh one thing Matt Ebor flues
Matt was the kind of linebacker coach
and been in Dallas for a long time he
came over in the hole kind of confusion
with Josh McDaniels
and they kept him on and Matt is a great
coach he knew a lot about that
Dallas offense for sure but he also knew
a lot about the Dallas defense and I
think he gave Frank Reich a lot of tips
on the type of run that would give
Dallas problem so I think that inside
information was a big help but also
those those kind of things
but I remember in Tampa in 1999 when we
went to the NFC Championship game and
lost to the RAM we were hot we won six
in a row we went out to Oakland we
practiced great and we lost 45 nothing
am i trainer you know what we're just
tired we need to get these guys some
time off they'll bounce back we came
back won the next two went to the
playoffs when all the way to the
championship game
sometimes these games happen and you
can't explain it just has to burn the
film and long during the Steelers
Patriots game I texted an ass and I said
how is Pittsburgh not great Tony it
feels like they have everything that you
want even their backup running backs are
running for a hundred yards you got
those wide receivers you have a defense
that puts pressure on you get sacks
why aren't they the team to beat in the
AFC they really City they're playing
good ball at times but not consistently
and you see the breakdown and even on
the last Drive you know there's a
35-yard past the Edelman when he's
uncovered you'd say how does that happen
in this situation but they certainly
have the people that they can put
together to a three game run and make a
lot of noise in the playoffs if they get
there how concerned would you be about
the Patriots I'm concerned because I
don't usually see this from them in
December not in games that mattered you
don't see 14 penalties you don't see
drop don't see Tom Brady making bad
decisions and the defense right and I
talk about it all the time where is
speed on the defense they just seem to
have problems with people that have
great speed on offense so they'll find a
way don't play well at home I don't
think they'll have a playoff game at
home but five horses on the road that's
uncharacteristic and if they have to go
on the road in the playoffs which they
will I think it's gonna be tough
how much blame do you put at the feet of
Aaron Rodgers with the Packers missing
out on the playoffs
well you know he's been hurt and not a
hundred percent so that's part of it I
don't think they've done a great job of
surrounding him with playmakers they had
a dynamic all offense at one point two
years ago it's not the same so part of
it is on Rogers but I don't look at that
front office is not really dressed and
well and replace those playmakers how
dangerous are the bears bears can be
dangerous because they've got pants for
instance they've got a defense that can
take the ball away and they've got a
creative offense they're gonna be a
tough out at home can they go on the
road and do it that's that's the
question but I don't think anybody's got
a lot of flavor yeah they've been an
interesting team there I look at some of
these teams like the Rams and the Bears
and I just feel like it comes down to
their quarterbacks with golf and true
Biscay can they make a big play when
they need to make a big play and that's
what the playoffs are all about you know
Patrick Mahone's I want to see what
happens when he gets into one of those I
gotta take this team down to score for
us to advance you know those kind of
moments there those you know that's what
separates these guys where you have
these Hall of Famers at the end of their
careers they're able to make those plays
I want to see the younger guys yeah
quarterback players gonna tell a big
story but I think it's your where
there's no great change
I do think New Orleans it's tough to
beat at home but it wouldn't surprise me
to see anybody get knocked off I don't
think there's two things going to say
these guys definitely gonna be in the
Super Bowl it's gonna be a great playoff
run when you're at the airport what's
the number one question you get you deal
in reality non-fantasy yeah another
question I get in New York yes hey coach
Edwards what are you doing you should
just pretend that you're her man words
we play to win the game that's all you
need to do
Tony safe travels my best to the family
and I'll talk soon
you guys have a great Christmas - if I
don't talk to you before
that's the Hall of Famer Tony Dungy
Continental Tire coaches corner
Continental Tire proud to be the
exclusive tire the Dan Patrick show no
matter where you drive what you drive
how you drive continental designs
Turner's for what you do for more
information visit Continental Tire kaam
Continental Tire for what you do for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show at
[Music]